Let's go to our caller from the six five zero.
Who's calling today from six five zero
he did.
Yes. Are we on speaker phone?
No, no, no. I'm on a headset here. This is
better.
That is better. Thank you.
Okay. Yeah, so, uh, I remember from my policy,
but my poly side days that there was something
in the constitution and I can't remember exactly
what it was, but there's something in it that
said that if the government basically just
did a really poor job of representing the
people of the United States and the people
United States felt that the government was
just overall corrupt, that there's something
in there and I can't remember exactly what
it is. And I'm hoping you might know what
I'm talking about, that the American people
can basically flush the whole government out
of all the representatives that we have in
the United States. Or we can remove everyone
from office one way or another is, did I remember
that incorrectly? Does that not exist?
You know, I, I unfortunately am not familiar
with exactly what you're describing. I mean,
I know about provisions like the 25th amendment
to remove an individual for lack of fitness,
but I'm not sure about this general sort of,
you know, flush the government down the toilet.
Uh, and that's maybe 10 or 15 times as Donald
Trump says. Some people are now flushing toilets
10 or 15 times. I'm not aware of that particularly.
Oh, okay. All right. Well, all right then
I'm probably mistaken or probably new to DC.
You don't know. It may be that, I just don't
know that it may be, you may be right. I just
am not sure.
Well, if anyone out there knows what I'm talking
about, I think because especially if, you
know, with all these polls, people are saying
that the majority of the people want the president
of the United States removed from office.
And if our government can't fulfill our desire
as the people, you know, they're supposed
to represent us. I mean, I think that's the
things that huge disgrace for how the government's
supposed to work. I think
there was no question. I mean, listen, what
you're pointing out is that government does
not really reflect the desires of the individuals.
And this is for a lot of different reasons.
This is because of voter suppression. This
is because very often they just don't do what
their constituents actually want them to do
because of a lobbyist influence in campaign
finance. You're spot on there. I mean, we,
we have the idea of a democracy, uh, of a
representative democracy and in practice we,
we barely have it.
Yeah. It's disgraceful. We need to flush them
right now.
Flush it 10 or 15 times my friend. Alright,
thank you so much for the call. I very much
appreciate it. Let's go next to our caller
from, uh, let's go to the five one six area
code. Who's calling today from five one six.
Good.
I think that's me. Hi, I'm Antwan from long
Island.
Hey Antonio. What's going on?
But that's an enormous, the man and a Mary
impeachment day.
Yeah. Yes, indeed.
Um, I really just had a Commodore question,
I should say. It seems like the Republican
party really only has two defenses right now
for what Trump had done. It's either that
he really didn't revolt, withhold the funds,
didn't offer a quid pro quo, um, and didn't
ask for a favor, which is have all been, uh,
shown to be false or everything he did was
okay. They say that the poll was OK, that
what Giuliani did was okay. And what he continues
to do asking for favors from other countries
is fine. So my question to you is, why can't
we get somebody like Nancy Pelosi, Nancy or
a Schumer or even better AOC, who's much better
at the trolling to kind of just stand up on
the house floor and say, Hey, Germany, if
you're listening, uh, could, if you get Trump's
taxes, I'm sure you'll be mightily rewarded
by the [inaudible]
I think somebody has done, I remember that
there was somebody who sort of tongue in cheek
did that. Um, but you're, you know, what you're
pointing out, Antwan is, is actually what
their defense has been for most things, which
is it definitely didn't happen. And then they
transitioned to, if it happened, it was okay.
And then they transitioned to it. It happened.
But it's fine. This is not anything to get
all worked up about it. I mean, remember they
said, Oh, nobody had any contact with Russians?
No, no, no, no. Nobody. Trump said it. Trump
jr said it. Penn said it, Jeff sessions said
it and then it switched to listen. I mean,
we have contacts, we talked to all sorts of
people and it's completely fine. This is how
it always goes. It didn't happen and it happened
and is not a big problem.
Exactly. But what I'm trying to get at is
that it seems like there's only two, um, two
change to results of what's going on, what's
going to happen with this impeachment, which
is one he gets removed from office when we
find out that, you know, you can't solicit
another government for help in an election
or two. He does it and then the rules of the
game have changed. So what I'm insinuating
is that someone in the house on the democratic
side should test that boundary instead of
a us pretending like he didn't ask or maybe
let's find out if he did. I would like to
see someone actually step up and you know,
say, Hey, Saudi Arabia, if you want us to
prove your, your weapon sale, which we will,
uh, you need to help us with corruption or
China, you need to investigate Ivanka Trump
and then we'll help you with the trade. Right?
Yeah. But who would do it? Who would do it
because it's Trump. Who's the one negotiating
all of that stuff? So you're, I mean, you're,
it's an interesting idea, but Democrats are
not in a position to demand those things because
Trump and his administration are the ones
managing those relationships.
Your a hundred, you're entirely
correct, which is, but at the same time, that's
why some why we didn't see, um, the PR Zelinsky
go on CNN. He kind of waited to the last moment
hoping the Congress would be able to, to step
over because Trump essentially isn't the universal,
uh, um, gateway into a M O w the favor that
he was asking for. All right. I think I understand.
I think it's a, it's an uphill battle, unlikely
to happen, but I appreciate the phone call
very much and, uh, and, and hope to hear from
you again